Robb's on twitter at dave ramsey is
there a reason that there's not an easy
way to close a credit card online why
can't I simply click a button yeah
there's a reason Rob the credit card is
the most marketed product in the history
of civilized man that is not an
exaggeration and then it's not hyperbole
more money has been spent selling you a
credit card then has been spent selling
you anything ever in the history of man
it is the most sophisticated marketing
the most thorough marketing to the point
that a vast majority of our culture
literally believe you cannot live
without a credit card they think you
can't exist on the planet without a
credit card the to suggest that you cut
up their credit cards would be suggest
that they die that's how good their
marketing is done how ingrained into our
cultural psyche that this product is
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars a year spent by Visa MasterCard
Discover American excess what's in your
wallet not a credit card money so all of
that to say they spend an immense amount
of dollars to get you to get a credit
card they don't want to make it easy for
you to get rid of what they spent so
much trying to get you to get they don't
want to make it easy for you to get away
from their product that they spent so
much effort brainpower and money trying
to get you to actually own it and now
that you finally own it the last thing
they want to do is make it easy some of
the most aggressive customer service
scripts you will ever experience or when
you call into a credit card company and
you're talking to Citibank and you're
trying to get them to cancel
they're stupid credit card you get in an
argument for 10 to 20 minutes with a
quote customer service in quote rep to
cancel your order
I mean think if you walked into a
restaurant and you said hey put my name
down for a reservation and then your
wife called and said honey well I'm not
coming the kids are sick and you go ok
and you walk up to the counter to cancel
your reservation and they argued with
you I mean you would just raise your
hands and touch downs fashion and walk
out right I mean it would be so
frustrating could you imagine doing
business with any other organization and
when you tried to cease doing business
with them they argued with you it's
pretty amazing if you think about it and
really shame you condemned you
how will you exist I mean what kind of
parent are you that you won't be able to
take care of your children if there's an
emergency I mean what if your mother
passed away on the other side of the on
the other side of the nation and you had
to buy an airline ticket how would you
do that if you didn't have a credit card
they will shame you on the phone to get
you to keep your credit card it's very
simple it's not evil in action or
anything like that it's just they have
spent a lot of money and some of the
most sophisticated marketing minds on
the planet prepare these customer
service scripts to retain the customer
to do a save they call it you call in to
cancel if they can talk you out of
counseling that's a save and they get
big credits for the save so the reason
that there's not an easy way to close a
credit card account online why can't I
simply click a button is that this is
the most aggressively marketed product
in the history of the world and you can
back that up with the dollars and
man-hours spent the brand penetration
that has occurred I mean the number of
people walking around with one to 10
credit cards boggles the mind
that's brand penetration it is wild
they have done a wonderful job can you
imagine the amount of money that I would
have made if the same number of people
owned a Total Money Makeover book that
owned a credit card I would be the
world's most successful marketer at that
point wouldn't I think about it what it
think about anything else I mean what
else does every body buy that's not a
necessity that everybody's sold
aggressively every time you turn on a
television there's another Hollywood
starlet pitching you a credit card
another Hollywood blockbuster former
washed-up movie guy doing a credit card
right I mean there and then when they
really get old they make them do reverse
mortgages hello Tom Selleck in the Fonz
we just got you okay but Henry Winkler
there we go you know I mean it's just I
like both those guys actually but it's
just those commercials are so freakin
cheesy they're so bad I mean that's when
your career really I mean you jump the
shark there Henry if you don't know
where jump the shark came from it was
actually a Happy Days episode so just
for those of you little trivia nuts out
there but anyway that's why you can't
cancel it Rob it's the most aggressively
marketed product in the history of the
world and that's not hyperbole that is
not exaggeration that is not drama
that's a statistical mathematical
financial fact there's more money spent
selling you that than selling you cars
there's more money spent selling you
that than selling you chocolate or roses
or haircare products or anything else
anything else there's not even a close
second and guess what they not only sold
it you bought it this is the Dave Ramsey
show